beh ci sono spari si sono che oggi
andremo a fare una challenge che so
perché richiesto in tanti non scegliere
lo shampoo sbagliato challange sly
musicare le ricordiamo tantissimi ciampi
con tantissimi shampoo siccità diciamo
tantissimi già parli così subito rumore
e merlino che si sta giocando questi
giochini e nuovi tiro allora
praticamente abbiamo tanti santi qua
però alcuni dentro hanno delle cose
schifose
e noi dobbiamo cercare di non pescare
quelli altrimenti rovineranno il nostro
slime trasparente cosa ci sarà nascosto
però in alcuni campi ci sono cose molto
belle ad esempio glitter e altre
sorprese quindi dovevo riuscire tre
fortunati pescare quelli belli ma io sto
normali piccoli gioco secoli normali
quelli belli quelli speciali e non
quelli sbagliati cioè fuori con le cose
schifose destra andare a mettete un bel
mi piace questo video dovrebbe vedere
altre slide challenge consigliate sicure
che altri slam tale se volete vedere
john nei commenti come sempre mettetevi
comodi prendere toni horror e tre gli
occhi prima bene ma molto liquido questo
shampoo vediamo ma che cosa pagherà non
becca i fatti tuoi preso uno shampoo
gigante sono inciampata su questo ho
preso questo nessuno oggi cante rosa
giusto in sala rosa ma devono patito
shampoo normale quello che si dice
questo se qualcosa che non va di sicuro
perché guardate i bisogni di melanzane
c'è qualcosa adesso sono poi è detto
quindi forse uno di quelli speciali non
di quelli sbagliati perché se le v nere
mai a teatro dipende però da che
colorante c'è dentro perché potrebbe
nascondersi parole del neo grigia
mandiamo giù prima di mamma cortisone
ok ecco quali sono tutti io mi sembra
proprio di quelli speciali perché a
tantissimi glitter vediamo che cosa ci
sarebbero si spezza lo speciale perché è
rotta con tanti glitter rossi e rosa che
bello bello
andiamo a mischiare bellissimo vorrei
già oggi sono 100 le bolle brigiotti
vanno così va purtroppo dove stare altri
scippi e forse ne pescare una brutta e
potrebbe rovinarlo speriamo che rimarrà
così bene mi chiamo un po tu hai uno
shampoo che mi sembra normale non vi
piace il colore che bello rosa infatti
sei stato fortunato anche tu e questo
non lascia un po speciale ma normale o
meglio minore su per te
tenete però c'è un buonissimo profumo
anzi è diventato parco che sono anche il
secondo treno come spendiamo fatto fatto
scusatemi ma d'impatto ad ora presidente
signor preso qualcosa anch'io è pronto a
girarlo molto pesante questo shampoo
vediamo ho preso ma santo blu l'anti
certo e trasparente
diamo una mossa davvero di questo valore
magari multato per con lo stare è paura
che sia molto bianco invece ok potrebbe
essere uno di quelli negativi avere
qualcosa libro nascondere qualcosa
dentro profuma di buono però prima
novità allora resta ho paura che
mettendo questo celeste diventi marrone
veniamo di know how e bellissimo il
colore di questa diventerà sicuramente
un altro brutto
vediamo se guardiamo un rock un po
anomala scurito un po è diventata una
sorta di viola sembra viola si rimette
un gattino tra il preferito in italia
propone i pianeti vi con le bollette che
belli sono in vantaggio però vediamo un
po se qua si nasconde qualcosa di
negativo speriamo di no
sembra quindi rimarrà bianco
è normale che ce n'è uno con la
trasparenza premi inventata con la
bianca non è giusto chissà se si
colorerà mai slime è un round pronti tre
[Musica]
peccato per l'acqua questo siamo
presenza pole c'è il beccuccio quantico
dosatore cosa interessante chissà se
giallo dentro sé di un altro colore
vedo delle macchioline che forse
un'edilizia sbagliato no io invece ho
preso da pretoria affrontano questo
marrone ne avete visto il video verde
contro marrone sapete che non li
affrontate non si sta molto bene stai
manzillo bronzo chrome e non lo fa
diventare un po luci del tipo glossy
vero che pare quindi per ottenere
diventare marrone e calmi olio
abbronzante vediamo come rovina il mio
slime adesso non vedo l'ora non vedo ora
[Musica]
oddio si sta espandendo parte l'evento
troppo bello marroncino di coca cola
scaduta però i viola è rimasto poco
molto poco di lei è un barboncino viola
dai non è male almeno spero che quando
l'ottimo sarà bello glossy lucido in
classe
vediamo il tuo invece che cosa vediamo
l'amica ferita di vedere cosa si
concentra beniamino bianco bianco blu
hai proprio tu non sia un po sbagliato
dai magari invece recuperarlo facendo
cooper anno guarda capo pensa che premia
umberto lavorare magari riesce a
salvarlo mark è il prossimo 26 32 e io
voglio duo anch'io voglio scarico al tuo
laus toccato questo non si sente niente
faccia qualcosa qua dentro
ernesto pronto c'è nessuno
vediamo wow bello che bellissimo questo
colore sono fortunato questa volta c'è
qualcosa di strano qua dentro notte a
giudicare dal colore mi sembra un po per
te nero e marrone poi il solito dentro
c'è qualcosa di strano
male lo so ho sbagliato magari ci sono
delle foglie averti dentro ai mercati
bello adesso di questo brutto come diamo
ecco qua vediamo cosa c'è qua dentro
e bellissimo attivo e tutto registro dei
pezzi settore verde
sono in atto deliziosi i pezzi di ieri
orribili league e odio
ecco adesso sembra davvero un galaxy
vedi non bello un po più scuro questo i
pianeti anche queste cose sembrano degli
alieni verdi se non avesse questi
galleggianti perdita sarebbe salvata un
pochino di venerdì ma peccato proprio lo
stampo peggiore è brutto invece sei
stato fortunato rilasciato fino a lato
con i glitter quindi ai quei scapito di
quelli spezza abbiamo riuscirai
finalmente a me ignorando il menti
dentro
wow mano alla colorato molto mi dispiace
ma il grigio è diventato nella sei
fortunato il laconi di terre riggi clima
grigio peter green deal in villa è il
cadetto non lo so è comunque meglio del
mio e mi è sembrata ok frasi molto male
per 3 2 1 siccome la sua ultima volta mi
è andato bene pescara da un'auto burton
è stato sconfitto a me no quindi io
pascoe dalla mia parte cercato questo
penso proprio che sia qualcosa di
normale perché la fossa spetta mi sembra
normale amica agosto sembra molto o no
che è stato io intanto sono fortunata
reward raffa guardate o forse qualcosa
che non va e questo shampoo ma è
completamente verde scuro o non so se
riuscite a vedere
doveva essere viola è diventato verde
scuro perde però se fosse andato per
come non lo abbiamo fatto e lo challenge
verde cosa scolti moratti perde sabato
marrone è però secondo me anzi è stata
ancora più più più intensa dato visto
che hai fatto un bellissimo sua in verde
ritorno ma ce ne sono capitati questi
questi pezzetti ben oltre quel verde che
vuole stare vicino a te quindi state
prese dall altro che starà bene con il
mio slide ignora se starà bene perché
potrebbe diventare marrone ma che diceva
face photomasi mi fermo vediamo ecco qua
il mio shampoo verde scuro neanche un
bertolino chiaro proprio umberto
scurissimo scoraggiate allora che bello
guarda come ci sta bene molto slide
dipenderà ancora più però più scuro
vediamo
sto diventando ancora più marroncino più
bello però secondo me diventerà un po di
chili perché c'è talmente tanto sciocco
che si vorrà una cooperativa bledar e
sarà un sacco ma che colore è questo non
si capisce non lo so in uso solo colore
brutto vediamo ora il suo lilla come
diventa per il celesti bellissime
stupendo un bel po di colore e giriamo
adesso siamo guardate un po più intenso
e farà mio bellissimo rimasto lille è
stupendo nuova diventato più potente
loro colori quello che più scuro ed è
bellissimo bene bene so che ha detto
vicino più bello il mio i ragazzi ultimo
turno quindi sono nati dai detto di aver
capito cosa o presto e cosa hai preso
quello al cioccolato
io feci ho preso questa rosa ma c'è
qualcosa dentro le palline che è
fortunato che 64 zarneri perché non lo
so se riusciranno a scendere invece va
il marrone come starò bastasse tutto lo
stipendio che alberto fa dietro oppure
barrare devo mettere via diego sarà
eretto io dico che non l'abbiamo ancora
attivato ma che forse se già un
vincitore
ecco qua mi lascia un po marrone allora
dichiarerà proprio questa sì sì renderò
di un fair marroncino intenso come un
cammello almeno buonissimo profumo
perché tu avevi della fiaccolata che ha
un delizioso
o alla fine colore da è stato soltanto
paese la gente a parte quella striscia
marroncina li spam è bravissimo si
capisce neanche che colore ma sembra più
tipo un viola scuro un po caduto come
dici tu sì è vero non vedo l'ora di
vederlo attivo speriamo che sia più
carino attivo al me invece metti in rosa
che diventerà un viola più chi ha
speriamo nostra piu l'iran sara dunque
lilla perché comunque molto delicato
operosa questa shampoo immaginiamo che
bello che tu mi piace lo stupendo il
minimo di atene sito veramente unga
recuperi la bellezza come nominato
fittante è tutto vero
nato il mio slide lillino lo chiama
tornando ebbene io sono stata super
sfortunate in questa cialente non si
muovono molto normale detto perché
magari una volta attivo è più bello il
mio che ne sai
ne dubito perché il mio gesto bellissimo
così figuriamoci io voglio benissimo i
suoi interventi privati potranno fare
allora cosa in italia vedremo andiamo ad
attivarli e poi potrete votare brutti 32
casa ecco qua il mio drive è uscito la
storta di gelatina molto belle bosa
pensavo che stesse uscendo un sigli ma
forse ho aggiunto troppo bicarbonato
forse troppi sappino l'hanno fatto
attivare bene ed è uscita beta gelatina
fa mi ricorda tantissimo il pokémon mas
selamat presente è uguale
infatti questo slam lo chiamerò max io
stavo continuando a perdere il sacco
società brutto era da un sacco chi non
missiva uno slide fei e lo scivolo sly
così ricordo proprio un mega slide same
sta continuando separarti tanti
pezzettini sembra tipo cervello di
pokémon
e terribile se stai fatto tutto il
tavolo non potete farvi sentire i suoni
sbr perché non c'è niente corazzi devo
devo cercare di raccoglierlo bene perché
sono ora si inonderà tutta la camera di
shampoo e bellissimo quindi queste le
mie terribile slime spain va bene sappia
avuto convinto allora devono stare e
dopo aver ripulito il tavolo a tutto il
casino che ha fatto la vita il vincitore
discusso di che spasso per challenge
guardate quante stupendo che mi sono
[Musica]
partito molto mia età è un bel po
stretti e poco poco grossi e sono
cicliche guardate anche un onore
bellissimo lisa chiaro troppo grigio è
un rigetto però vediamo se fa le
bollicine non così ma c'è ma guardate
che il colore scelto per il duo a tutti
i glitter in vernacolo mese insieme da
un po di rigetto poteva essere un po più
lilla o più violetto però
non ci possiamo lamentare rispetto a
quello di carità che ben si capisce che
cosa ha ucciso abbiamo dovuto ripulire
tutte la mentalità come fatto il sito di
bere tuenti un po cinica perché io sono
diventato bravissimo con lo smile sei
stato fortunato ho superato
super scoppiettante che fortuna invece
sappiamo mazzucco di smile la zuppa
questo bellissimo slime cicli milla i
ridotti modellino guarda che con il gol
in meno
il terzo superfortunate prestanza te mi
raccomando lasciato un mi piace di
conforto per il mio stile è stato quello
che ti è piaciuto di più in questo caso
di lime colori sanchez
andate a vederlo fila sotto la
cartellina per vederle tutte sono belli
sono state super divertenti da fare tra
l'altro e poi mila su altre tre
cartellini su cui cliccare per vedere
inoltre altri video che cade su quella
che preferite e buona visione
ciao